okay so today is versus people of the
French Resistance me history and I'd
like to say that the French Resistance
today enjoys a quiet and Dylan status
because for a long time it has been
considered as a phenomenon of major
importance this optimistic view like
amongst women dealers first thanks to
the shallow body France have been able
to liberate itself alone this statement
in the specific saliva has led neuronal
infinite variation of the country which
was as you may suppose quite a biased
view of the French to participate into
the resistance this conception was both
imposed by cyclists and by the Buddhists
all of them pretended that we she had
read in the cupboard state deprived of
any legitimacy residence at last and I
think it's very important to mention
happen to stress to strengthen that
resistance was considered as a military
phenomenon this conceptual stated that
what we call civil resistance was of no
importance compared to the Maquis or to
the battle struggle one example
shows this vision as you know a great
fight and burst out in 1941 major 1941
in the hospital a so-called miners have
striped and more than 200 and surgical
miners have been deported to Germany but
they have not been considered as
resistors until 1962 why people say
where the French authorities say they
were struggling for which application
for which is increasingly corporatist
resistance Wow from the end of the 60s
however this vision as you know has
collapsed and the new conception as the
murder
No so resistance appears to be a
minority
instead majority phenomenal Syrian
resistance and of course the rescue of
the Jews take the greater part why the
military dimension has quite totally
vanished and the resistance as we can
say that has been attacked in the last
20 years who has been doubled against in
the book by trans to Athena
twelve in a Soviet agent which is a
transitory
document also Surya recently Mubarak you
certainly know these that this famous
couple of resistors and also accused to
have betrayed all these elements could
be considered as a vertical if they did
not reveal to a certain extent crude
loss of prestige in total income to
reference resistance is zero reference
but is to a certain extent of mind to
defend a friend which was obviously not
the case twenty or thirty years before
but if the me as correct we can say also
as Robert Paxton as a structure the
history of the resistance has not yet
been written in fact right history of
the French resistance is quite difficult
remember that the archives have been
closed to a large extent until 1979
which means that history have been
mostly based upon oral testimonies or I
regret to say that resistors have been
liars so it's a problem you see - best -
to make history of the resistance just
about the resistors determine the
resistance miss also have been so strong
that many historians have for new type
of ain't the kind of safe Center as much
as many veterans were quite powerful
just think of Google so this trend has
vanished
okay but it has not totally disappeared
in October 8th Prince
so this broad picture in science to deal
with too many mythic topics has
resistance played the MIT report and
some part has it been able to involve
the majority of French in the struggle
you you may notice that I am using a
plan which is in two parts
which is Plato tryna for a French term
if you use sweet parts so the first
question is has a resistance of the
French Resistance play Dimitri part so
to deal with this very important stake
first flight obliged to consider the
matrix of the French Resistance has it
been stoners or an exogenous phenomena
well the two of them we can say as a
three main actors intervene in the
process
cyclists the Brits and the French so to
boost the Buddhist mythology has always
considered that resistance has a Warner
was to result all the favors our deal
now by jihad the water you see the
picture has been taken in 1941 but this
this is pose
iconic photograph of the room the idea
so that resistance was born thanks to
the Athena betrayed both reality and the
good vision so back to basics
what was the world religion according to
him war in 1940 was not over because it
was a world war it was as important to
maintain France in the world in it in
order to are to be considered after the
war as a winner so to do so the girl
refused to create a legend fighting with
the race and if referred to build a
condo state in England and then as you
know in Algeria this stage yes sir tea
would be able to embody the true friends
and to capitalize on the national basis
its mystery games
so to make friends survive in the war
Google tried to rain some French
colonies such as the frequently and
process he created a new Free French
forces which fought in the desert in
Libya and then organized secret services
so this very happy Syria BC air and
ocean you know ataxia which were the
secret police secret services which will
make to them as so the PC era was
supposed to create what we call them
networks in book my friends which
received three main tasks first of all
gathering me tree information to give
this ministry information such as for
example
German order of battle it was equally
supposed to end
I saw Delta mostly by us to be a rich
dude and he was poor it was also
supposed to say German resources which
has been made at station and the briefs
were quite anxious to know what was the
scientific device where the scientific
devices the Germans used so they send a
party to to this the destroyed and even
a German officer some information is
read ethical basic library 1942 but all
these priorities clearly show chapter
who was not leading of a against the
axis this policy was not worth criticize
them because the world considered that
Peters been trainer was not to have been
impossible regimen but to assign the
shiny a mystery see that mean that
denouncing the national revolution
authenticity prosecution well clearly
not the whose main goals even if of
course hatred
personal brand this oval policy that
means also that Google was not
interested in evolving in importing the
French in the struggle and war was
supposed to be led by specialist degree
of soldiers and secret agents
even if these secret agents were
sometimes amateurs
for example inheritance of rest able to
describe the movements of the peaks
Medina for example to a large extent
please share this view in 1940 has no
churchy church it has created special
organizations SOP Special Operations
Executive which was supposed to set
Europe ablaze so to do so the ESCO
created networks which were spying
strategy and rescuing our soldiers but
the Greeks were quite reluctant to up
the French and were certainly not
planning or not only on the arena they
did not want an uprising for two main
reasons
first of all they said severe reprisals
on the other hand they were afraid to
attract German divisions German forces
to the French the actor of operations
which in case of landing in northern
France would be disastrous for obvious
strategy reason so for all these reasons
the breeze refused for long time too
weapons to the French Resistance and
were opposed to the Maquis and the
French the fraction have been struck by
the defeat and the majority of them were
confident in baton but a few of them
wanted to do something the end however
was not necessarily metering one son of
course wanted to help the Allies and the
British at first to win the war the head
joint so networks which were looking for
to be Sierra easily or even the secret
services for them war was an overriding
priority for the hazards of whether war
was not a problem
they knew that they were totally unable
to threaten the German forces especially
in 1940 1941 so they were Iranian
occupation which was according to them
early and concrete reached maximum
jeopardize the French sour residence had
s father's good to preserve and to
protect against the Germans which were
plundering the country which were also
training to
Merrifield the country so these men and
women tried to create the new form of
organization movement the movement was
supposed to see public opinion and it
often diffused promised time leaflets
such as Yahoo Kumar the most familiar
the first kind of leaflet so you see
them not very well pretty it's a very
very bad paper but after the quality
improvement and the color style effects
were even able to publish photographs
which was quite quite impressive because
of course they were closed this time and
prosecuted by estoppel or the vicious
vicious police giving good information
was the best way to contradict tonight
of the Germans or of the vicious
propaganda but understand newspapers
could also intercept mobilizes the
French a kind of secret money and in the
third step this secret army would be
able to help the Allied forces just
before and after telling many movements
of course work in to help the Allies by
rescuing the pilot by giving the Allies
some piece of information but this task
however well not their primary goal so I
think that we can consider that there is
a gap between the networks and the
movements because the networks were
leading the war and the other were
resisting the German occupation the
first was struggling for
and the similar were claiming for
liberation and liberation and victory
it's not the same kettle of fish and the
resistance was diverse from the onset it
was a mughal their image in great
britain gesture of human tears join the
Secret Service season which were not
well considered because the shadow war
was not a war of gentlemen
it was bankers also as secret agents
were not protected by Geneva Conventions
invite friends resistance was also very
dangerous so we can even animation rough
estimate a revelation in 1941 I think
that resistance to the whole amount in
thirty thousand people on a global
population of 40 of forty billion it was
in fact a very risky charm but I think
also that a natural element played great
part I mean that the movements were
unable to eat clear instructions clear
guidelines to the population what could
the state say just say adult dignified
attitude
to avoid or the lady to see we
but after that what was possible
nothing was possible to be done because
they had no weapons they had no
instructions realized were supposed to
land in France so the resistance
movements were to a certain extent in a
deadlock they were totally unable to
propose concrete ways of fighting even
the assassination of german soldiers
which were trained by the communists on
an actor august 1941 well not an
efficient means of action and the
environment subcommittee reprisals that
even the communists told that they were
not due to the communist party that they
were due to married people doing that on
their own idea and not obey communist
instruction so to a certain extent the
resistance was the bedrock was not a
drug but the beauty occurred in 1940
first of all many friends were confident
in but not many passes in 1942 the
Empire was freed by the alive thanks to
the landing in North Africa the Germans
invaded in retaliation so called treason
in November 1942 and the French state
showed that it was unable to protect its
citizens
it was unable to protect the citizens
begins war as the bonding of
metropolitan
began food pressure food rationing
increased and vision and force force
force labor generally first labor is to
admit introduced in February 1943 where
three classes of workers but remember
that alone on the fourth of September
1940 jube has played a more important
rule on the amount of six thousand and
fifty thousand workers more than three
hundred thousand have been sent to
Germany because of this loop of
September 1942 which I think quite a
surprise at the beginning of the 21st
century when historians when French
historians have discovered this teacher
so first labor has been a very very
important element total resistance in
occupied France because as you know many
friends were reluctant to work in
Germany even if many we're not so
reluctant to work for traveling but what
in Germany to opportunity is not the
same see so many of them became drug
doctors which was both the chance and
the burden for the inner resistance
first liver was obviously great athletes
for the inner resistance first of all
because it increased the number of
volunteers of course all not all
Rogers did not China so resistance maybe
tried to dodge visa system for example
by working in the mines which was the
way to escape
requisition authors probably 250,000
just people but the red and the red that
means 50,000 people which was quite
quite a very impressive about join the
underground and went to the magic first
labor equally offered another
opportunity to the resistance the
movements were able to give clear
commands to the population and the
others were easy to obey it was not so
difficult for example to hide a man in
the farmer it was not so difficult to
give him false papers in a small village
so from this point of view first labour
had been a great opportunity for the
inner resistance but it has also been a
burden because the French movements were
suppose to feel and to sector thousands
of volunteers and they were not prepared
to do so so all these elements have
arrived the inner resistance and the
Buddhists to reconsider their relations
and that is
and of the 1942 Nutini as a very they
have told the world was not really
interested in the movement but akkad
recently changed his mind because the
world realized that rate would offer the
basis for secret army and equally
realized that the rules could broaden
his legitimacy so he was keen to control
them for ministry not for political
purposes to be efficient the movement
had to be integrated into global war led
by alive and these were required unique
command so political and metric reasons
combined to incite the world to impose
tight control on these boxes but the
movements on the other hand maybe the
world ended because in 1942 they were
growing which means that they needed
money and needed weapons especially in
the Maki after November 1942 so so the
link between the two banks of the
channel had to be strengthened for this
reason the world sent delegates from the
scene photograph in occupied France in
January 1942 he had three been tasked to
unite the movements in the south to
organize a secret army and in the civil
step which intervened in February 1943
to
natural concealer of the resistance a
New Zealand resistance which was
supposed to gather all French political
parties all Frenchmen Union internal
resistance movements I don't want to
spare much time on this questions but to
a large extent
munna have succeeded in this mission so
the networks and the Romans were more
closely linked to London thanks to Jean
and to a certain extent they obeyed the
rules all but what will they what was
suppose to do the war I have said that
attached to greatest importance to me
tree intelligence from this point of
view so this era as we have really been
deficient many telegrams informed Elijah
also German defenses according for
example to general to know who was in
charge of z/os 80% of the information
used to prepare the lava have been given
by the French resistance for stability
however the French resistance was less
successful just huge changes occurred
before the day so of course you are here
kind of iconic photographs we French
saboteur and when network you have here
the result of an attack in January 1944
but all the holidays
may before to 1944 have not really put
in danger the German war machine but the
French resistors received the special
mission for d-day they were supposed
across plan suppose return to nice
so anyway Network and the result of the
action launch on the 5th of June 1944
has been a success
and it's mainly result was to slow the
rate adjustment of the German troops so
separatism to an end and intelligence of
the other were quite important but they
were not the only nations devoted to the
French resistance to other possibilities
remained open the Maquis international
arising many young men joined the Maquis
in 1943 so the West to maintain the high
Indian census but what was supposed to
do - I'll fight the British were too
close to the machines which were
according to them the total maintenance
since no landing was planned as you know
the decision of the Lord has been taken
at the end of the member 1943 hence the
refusal to even weapons as much as the
air preferred bombing and so the air
refusal to divert their precious bombers
for such an Atari games the goodest
we're a little bit more open although
they thought that the matches were not
ready to fight but they hope that the
machine could play a role during the
liberation of the country and according
to them
two men Mac is good movie into the hole
in the French Alps and the aim of the
man she was secured through the moon
into massive Rock Island to catch a
possible German retreat from Atlantic
coast and the movements at last were
equally divided the Communists disliked
the monkeys because according to them
the fight had to be led in total and not
in the countryside for the useless arena
the other forces were less reluctant
even if they did not really know which
strategy was being forced was the match
is supposed to hide from destiny
soldiers we will fight just before the
Allied landing or could eat lunch
offensive before and this question was
not pretty settled at the eve of 6th of
June well the French addressed supposed
to make an insurrection in April 1942
the worldwide incautiously
have learned the famous motto according
to him National Liberation and national
appraising work to be fully linked and
this formula was retaken by the
communists but as you may suppose for
other reasons
in fact the bullet failure and the
pricing but it's subordinated this
uprising to two conditions it had to be
as short as possible and it had to be
closely linked to the operation of the
electrons so communists on the contrary
we're anxious to launch an insurrection
as soon as possible
their dream was to welcome to Berlin not
as a generator but in a country treated
by their own forces which was not the
same process the 6th of June July then
realized lately
nobody and so trans as I said we're to a
large extent a success especially for
railways but the maxi's were not so much
even for example group in in in the June
July 1944 you see here showing these
young men living as schools in the
internet oh but the Germans decided to
destroy machine in July and
well you see here the symmetry of quiet
more than a hundred and forty friends
were killed and more than 200 civilians
and the same story occurred at mouche
and to a certain extent as a master in
greeting so generally speaking the
matches have been a failure for two main
reasons
alaya have not really supportive because
they were not interesting from a
strategic point of view and they were
totally unable to fight especially
especially the phrasing was equally a
failure of course it's very difficult
for us to understand this failure
because we think of Paris within the
City of Lights but Paris is an exception
and is certainly not alone in fact the
main French cities 212 only five men and
insurrection which was quite a few
reasons why because first arose the
Communists were too weak to launch
balloon and apprising because the
resistors were truly out and because of
course the French had no time right
either because of the German retreat
other than Eclair of the 60s of who
for all because of the fastness of the
other atoms after July 19 stress not by
a magnet after that the French territory
has been very very quickly operating so
there was no room for a French
interaction so control has the French
Resistance play Dmitry part this
question requests a balance and answer
yes if we consider the question in terms
of piece of intelligence in turn equally
or savatage's but certainly not if we
take into account some axis so we can
consider that France would have been
liberated with or without the French
resistance does it mean however that the
French have been passive has adjusted
adopted during the world awakens the
attitude hazard and to commit themselves
in the struggle this is of course a very
very difficult question and I'm like now
to deal with this question with a
question of commitment first of all we
have to mention that the German
occupation has always been popular
collaboration has never been popular
moto and maternity of fresh hatred
the Germans this aid was sometimes based
upon a very strong traditional Japanese
food which was of course fueled by the
remembrance of war but it was also
sometimes fueled by a very strong aunty
Netezza this feeling however did not
prevent the French to work for the
Germans of trade with them and you know
that Swiss historian as clearly showed
that many French have adopted the
strategy of accommodation with the
Germans the accommodation was I think
more way to survive them to support the
nazy new order we have hands to make a
clear distinction between the logics of
opinion and the logics of action many
friends were against the German
occupiers but just a few were ready to
thank them and so this discrepancy has
to be taken into consideration
first of all resistance has often been
represented as an ideological fight
mobilizing for example Patriots or
entity faces this vision of course is
true for genealogy has played an
important part in commitment but she
cannot consider just ideology as single
element because resistors were of course
painting for values freedom human rights
and so on but I think that if the values
importance sir high ranking of the
values were more natural importance just
take two examples see from you and
khadijah fill of you and inhibitor well
- member of the French parliament before
the war they belong to the same party
the Federalists replica both words which
was a rightist
party both were article list both were
Catholics
both were nationals both agreed with
papers national revolution of you
however supported collaboration that
bigger joined the resistance as soon as
in 1940 as soon as 1940 why because you
thought that versatile retain and so
when the life launched its crusade
against Moscow and you thought that it
was is duty is duty to support the this
kind of they be able to confirm it so
that the French nation had to preserve
its independence towards Germany and so
it broke with beta as soon as October
1940 he would telegrams to be conceived
your policy your inner policies mothers
your ideas are modest but first of all
just put soldiers out of friends and
after
and for this marvelous policy so you see
the cell values have entail have
involved very different consequences and
the state dilemma strikes a community
because the leaders wanted to teach
Soviet Union so until June 1941 they
focused their attacks against Russia and
they can't be avoided to criticize the
Germans because of course of the Soviet
of determines of the pact of 1939 that
other authors of the country were upset
by the defeat and the library egg was to
fight Nazi Germany and so they
immediately got involved in the struggle
as trashcan one in Jerusalem but you
cannot say that you are a resistor if
you do not lead an action so how to lead
an action this action I think have to
obey to hold it add first of all to
respect your own principles and from
this point of view it was not always
obvious it was written by was very
difficult for Christian to kill a German
because of the seeds of n du shalt not
kill and another element was also very
important
the action was supposed to be addition
because it was a risky one but what does
efficient mean for video teasers
to distribute from the state needless
was totally Chinese you cannot win the
war by distributing clue design defects
you cannot defeat an enemy with Network
for a Christian on the contrary word
where crucial in the beginning was the
word
so commitment was to a certain extent
the result of supply and demand on the
third side the resistance organizations
as we have seen have been able to a long
time to give clear instructions to the
French but many French were not ready to
commit themselves because they thought
that the means of action were totally
useless and one very good example I
think is on a manual on the novel who
was a very bold man who have been very
courageous during the Spanish War who
have been very courageous in 1939
because I am listed in self was not
allowed to fight in the French army so
even until to be to be attractive but
but it refused to support resistance and
when the famous resistor grupo de came
to see him Matthew said do you have
money do you have weapons look okay come
back when you in get out and money so
these elements show I think the
importance of cultural factors all
social groups were not able to face the
situation
in the same way to a certain extent so
we're ready to fight to face contesting
life for example but others were not but
what does ready mean I think that it
means students first of all I think that
some groups went by dicted to commit
themselves in the resistance because of
their rectory of action this concept
preventive actions to eat it group
chants de says has its own repertory of
actions to demonstrate how to strike how
to make leaflets and he had some times
before experiment especially when he had
food during the Spanish Civil War it was
of course sometimes assistant to produce
a knife so 21 conditions imposed in 1992
join the committee of light the French
Communist Party to create the secret of
our matrix and remember also that the
French Communist Party have been
forbidden in September 1939 so many
leaders died in from the tightness for
all these reasons the Communists were
too large
except ready to get involved in the
resistance but it was not the case for
some of the basic students what did he
know we had nothing to offer except
maybe his ability to think and write and
this day to explain why so many students
joined movement
cutter
networks ready equally manage that
pre-world captures interested with
commitment and especially political
cultural political non marks help to
identify the enemy but to identify an
enemy is not always obvious for Earth's
perseverance obvious that Macedon was
the alien but four of you per season was
a much better evidence for very greatest
officer beta was not a traitor
so to identify to identify the foe is
not a person here in the American
context we could ask a question of the
Tea Party Friends of of the Republican
Party it's a good question I think of
the Republicans to be to be asked so if
the very condition of the soul is not
really easy to say for a sport for
example the ecology of the green in
front of a friend it's a very difficult
question to go with so some background
he'll remain and I think has to be
present or considered when you see the
difference between the Jews and the
Christian Democrats what was the
Christian Democrats before the war in
France
no it was not so common in the Catholic
world remember that that had been signed
between building in 1934 and many
Catholics thought that medicine was a
good war against Bolshevism in France
Christian Democrats were immunized
against such an illusion because they
considered that medicine was a mechanism
during the interwar period the tests had
warned against the Navy strength threat
3 and so to a certain extent Christian
Democrats were immunized against any
illusion they were equally Renekton
toward Pitta and it was not so common
you see the Christian is the Catholic
world of occupied France because they
aim to reconcile the church and the
Republic hazard to restore a mobile
order and they will not afraid to
disobey because they used to do so on ad
condemning them several times in 1910
when the co and in led to set
dissolution in 1934 when said the
Medical Review was considered as a
communist with you and had been obliged
to disown itself they were not afraid to
die because in the thirties spirituality
prayed matadormon
and referred to exact Jesus Christ dead
on the Holy Cross hazard
the Mary last but not least resistance
was to a certain extent as related to a
return 12 original purity a prosecuted
minority was leading the desperate
struggle as the first one Christians did
in the catacombs and for all these
reasons the Christian Democrats got
involved in the shadow army as soon as
1940 just search Surrey has not been the
case for many Jews except the Communists
because Jews many Jews were totally
confident in France which was the
country of human rights many of them did
not believe that Peter could deliver
them to the jurors from the cultural
point of view many Jews were not ready
to disobey the law because to respect
the law was a way to show that they were
faithful to France it was equally a way
to put aside a common criticism
amplified by the Dreyfus Affair Jews
were cold and bothersome traitors many
truly thought that their sacrifice could
be a way to avoid friends to pay a
higher tribute to the Germans and one
example clearly shown clearly shows his
friend when it was Allah he is not very
famous but he was a teacher in
philosophy
and as a Jewish teacher he was not to
resign but when did in do it is last
class to Socrates and you know and
Socrates referred has referred to obey
the laws of Athens even who they were
unjust hazards and condense them so the
example given to the student was that
regard was the insurrection it was who
as I do
I am I am drinking is you hazards and
disobey the so it's time to conclude on
just three points first from a military
point of view the French resistance has
been an effect but this effect has just
played a major part in the liberation of
the country the Allied would have won
the war with the French Resistance as
without it to resistance has remained
the matter phenomenon in occupied France
which could appear paradoxical taken
into account the Germans in popularity
commitment however did not obey to
feelings it also depended on what
resistance organizations were able to
offer and from this point of view so
guidelines were quite
until 1942 or even 1943 commitment
commitment equally dependent on cultural
factors so when for example you consider
efficiency your repeater ease of actions
and all these elements were very
different according to social or
cultural groups we can help consider
that resistance and desert just a
minority of French for all these reasons
maybe half a million in 1944 these two
elements are of course deeply linked
resistance has not been able to play
metal role because it has always been me
and this bedroom explains for example
that national uprising trend even in a
different way both communist and the
dualist have been a failure but this
failure however mesons hi another danger
resistance has been strong enough to
avoid the civil war and to proceed in a
very peaceful way the devolution of
power between reality and the Buddhist
regime have been very peaceful this has
not been the case
in Greece that means that I think that
resistance has played a very important
role but on political rant that is as
mr. Cruz another story